so if i'm reading this right the
encryption tool that almost all websites
use to protect my private data and even
my passwords basically hasn't been
working right awesome okay so heartbleed
which is what they've been calling this
bug is being patched by major sites to
make things safe going forward once the
website is patched it's a good idea to
change your passwords all my passwords
okay this is no time to panic today I'm
going to do three things to make sure
I'm safe you should do them to number
one take inventory of all the sites that
may have sensitive information that
means email bank accounts credit card
sites shopping sites like Amazon and
Social Network Accounts check the
website SS labs com / SSL test to see if
they've been patched if they all get a's
they're good companies such as yahoo are
also announcing when they've been
patched once they've been patched change
that password change passwords at the
most important sites first anything
where your reputation or your money is
at stake then set aside another day to
deal with your other accounts number to
create new and strong passwords and
don't use the same password twice
seriously don't use that same password
again use a combination of letters
symbols and numbers here's a good trick
though create one password for your
social media accounts then tweak that
password with different numbers or
phrases keeping track of all of those is
a pain so you may want to use a password
manager like 1password 3 turn on 2-step
verification that's a security feature
that many web services offer this is a
second confirmation of who you are in
addition to your password when enabled
after you type in your password you get
a text message with a special code that
you input unless someone steals your
phone and your password you should be
safe you might have to go digging to set
this up though gmail calls it 2-step
verification facebook calls it login
approvals and yahoo calls it second sign
in verification make of america calls it
safe paths it might seem annoying to
have to get that code but it is worth it
okay I'm feeling much better now I did
yoga I breathed i reset my passwords I
set up two factor authentication you
should do the same I promise you'll feel
better